number one for school zones when is a
school zone active there's three
different ways to know
if children are present if the lights
are on or 30 minutes before or after
school those are all indicators that it
is an active school zone
the laws that we need you to make sure
that we're following as we approach
monday and throughout the rest of the
school year
commissioner nafta mentioned these
number one no u-turns in an active
school zone
number two no passing another vehicle in
a school zone so what that means real
quick is if the speed limit is 15 miles
an hour in that school zone
and someone's going 10 or 11 miles an
hour the new speed limit is basically
going to be 10 or 11 miles an hour
you're not allowed to pass another
vehicle
in an active school zone and finally
speed
speed kills we have extremely low
speed limits in the school zones and
that's for designed
to eliminate that possibility of a
fatality to happening
so we need to make sure that the public
is participating in those
slower school zones